what happened out there Isabel five
months ago the portal from the ark to
earth shut down without warning a month
later he arrived he the fruit their
leader
his name
is a tree ox during the war the Covenant
used his clan as expendable muscle told
them dying in battle would speak their
holy Journey and none ever returned
until he did
and so battle by battle war by war a
tree ox was born with every victory his
Legend and his hatred crew eventually
both were impossible to conceal and they
tried to banish him in everything we
know about the covenants thousand-year
history a tree ox was the first to defy
the Covenant
and survive and his defiance inspired
others
the Covenant had two targets in those
years
they almost go to us
but a tree ox
never came close
we don't stop them now
we leave the galaxy at the mercy of a
monster he killed everyone I was
supposed to protect
and this great it will be over
that is what you're up against James
cutter we need to run as far and as fast
as we can
you
you